[Musica]
io sono maria chiara carrozza e sono
originaria di pisa e sono qui a siena
per parlarvi delle ricerche del
consiglio nazionale delle ricerche della
sua storia e
sono molto contenta di essere qui in
toscana perché la toscana ha una
grandissima tradizione di ricerca
scientifica delle atenei molto
importanti però il mio messaggio di oggi
è proprio che noi non conosciamo la
storia dei nostri atenei la storia della
ricerca che noi svolgiamo nei nostri
atenei nel consiglio nazionale delle
ricerche nei nostri istituti e non
conosciamo i personaggi che hanno fatto
oggi
che hanno portato oggi la ricerca quella
che è che hanno costruito l'ossatura del
nostro sistema della formazione della
ricerca e mi sono ispirata a una
professoressa che si chiama giuseppina
aliverti una accademica dei lincei che è
morta nel 1982 è nata a somma lombardo e
morto a napoli e ha avuto una storia che
è particolarmente interessante la
giuseppina aliverti pensate qui ci sono
i documenti che abbiamo trovato dentro
l'archivio del cnr è stata incaricata
nel 1940 di dirigere un osservatorio
geofisico di pavia perché è importante
questo prima di tutto perché è
importante perché è una donna che ha
raggiunto i massimi livelli anche della
ricerca e della ricerca per lo stato ma
perché in quegli anni si costruì quello
che poi oggi è l'istituto nazionale di
geofisica e vulcanologia il cnr cioè
agli istituti di ricerca che svolgono
non soltanto ricerca ma anche una
funzione molto importante il
monitoraggio del territorio
e in effetti in quegli anni e qui si
vede proprio il decreto con cui fu
istituito l'osservatorio e fu dato
proprio a lei giuseppina aliverti perché
è importante la sua storia perché lei
era una fisica che ha studiato fisica e
poi gradualmente ha cominciato a
studiare la terra l'osservazione della
terra la geologia e ha fatto tante cose
importanti che oggi
hanno prodotto e producono quello che
oggi svolge il consiglio nazionale delle
ricerche
qui è un altro esempio che ho portato
che è molto interessante che potete
vedere nel documento perché il consiglio
di presidenza del cnr del 1957 ha
destinato una serie uno stanziamento
importante per costruire e partecipare
la partecipazione italiana all'anno
della geofisica e internazionale qui
vedete la foto sono tutti gli uomini ci
sono solo due donne e una di queste era
giuseppina aliverti che in effetti era
già a quei tempi molto importante quindi
subito diciamo nel dopoguerra costruito
quello che oggi noi siamo e vi farò
vedere perché la sua storia si incrocia
con quella di un altro personaggio molto
importante del consiglio nazionale delle
ricerche che è il suo primo presidente
che fondò nel
1923 il consiglio nazionale delle
ricerche dalla accademia dei lincei
perché è importante la sua storia perché
noi fu il primo presidente e fu anche
uno degli accademici italiani che non
aderì al partito fascista ea in
conseguenza della sua non adesione perso
è praticamente tutto e fu anche un po
cancellato dalla storia tanto è vero che
molte persone pensano che il primo
presidente del cnr sia stato guglielmo
marconi in realtà guglielmo marconi è
stato il secondo presidente e cosa fece
vito volterra non solo fondò il cnr con
una idea importante cioè che il paese
doveva avere un consiglio nazionale
delle ricerche perché le ricerche erano
importanti per l'avanzamento e
scientifico e per il futuro del paese
per il suo futuro anche in campo
industriale ma fece un altra cosa che è
molto importante
fondo gli istituti tra l'asso grafici
che per esempio io ho visitato molto di
recente oggi sono confluiti negli
istituti del mare del cnr a messina a
messina davanti al canale di messina c'è
il punto dove c'è il istituto del cnr
che oggi si chiama istituto di ricerca
del mare ed è di fronte al canale si
vedono proprio confluire le correnti
quindi un punto fondamentale in cui
cominciò a registrare il mare correnti
il tempo tutte le condizioni fisiche
geofisiche che erano fondamentali che
poi hanno costituito le serie storiche
che oggi usiamo per capire gli effetti
del cambiamento climatico e quindi nel
poco qui c'è proprio nel 1917 questo
bollettino bimestrale fondo acquisti
istituti thalasso grafici una venezia
anche a venezia nella laguna di venezia
c è un istituto di ricerca sul mare che
oggi insomma raccolto quelle estere dita
ma se noi oggi possiamo andare nel
passato e utilizzare le serie storiche
delle misure del mare che ci permettono
di capire oggi cosa è successo e come si
è evoluto e l'impatto del cambiamento
climatico è perché qualcuno a quei tempi
ha pensato dal niente di fondare gli
istituti dall'astro grafici e perché è
questo è importante perché oggi noi
abbiamo un consiglio nazionale delle
ricerche con 8.700 ricercatori su tutto
il territorio italiano e quello che è
bello da mostrare che la ricerca che noi
svolgiamo si svolge sul campo proprio
letteralmente sul campo per studiare le
nuove coltivazioni oppure si svolge ai
poli i poli sono gli eredi negli
istituti al palazzo grafici di allora
perché le registrazioni che noi
svolgiamo ai poli sono in un certo senso
i rivelatori nello stato climatico del
pianeta quindi perché l'italia va ai
poli uno dice sembra una cosa assurda in
realtà ai poli le basi che noi abbiamo
sono le basi dove si studia l'impatto
del cambiamento climatico e lo stato del
clima e perché questa missione del cnr
cioè del consiglio nazionale delle
ricerche così come degli altri enti di
ricerca
gli enti di ricerca hanno una funzione
molto particolare che quella
dell'avanzamento scientifico ma anche
quella di svolgere una missione a
servizio del paese l'osservatorio
geofisico di che dirigeva di pavia che
dirigeva giuseppina aliverti serviva
proprio anche a questo e oggi noi
abbiamo un articolazione territoriale
vedete 227 sedi 88 istituti torniamo un
attimo a giuseppina aliverti cosa fece
da aveva studiato fisica ma gettò le
basi di quella che oggi è la geofisica
l'agevole moderna e quello che noi oggi
facciamo qui vedete alcune degli esempi
di come si è interessata
all'applicazione della scienza alla
descrizione del mondo e all'applicazione
della scienza per descrivere le
situazioni geofisiche e per sviluppare
strumenti che permettessero una cosa
fondamentale che noi oggi dobbiamo
capire misurare per comprendere perché
per comprendere per esempio il
cambiamento climatico se noi non
misuriamo e non sviluppiamo
infrastrutture che effettuino queste
misure registrino i dati e li mettano a
disposizione della comunità non usciamo
non riusciamo a modellare a predire
quello che succederà guardate cosa ha
fatto nel
1970 ha scritto un trattato
sull'utilizzo dei satelliti di seconda
generazione per la mia terra
l'osservazione della terra quindi aveva
capito nel 1970 quale poteva essere
l'utilizzo dei dei satelliti poi aveva
capito l'integrazione fra oceano e
atmosfera e quindi si era utilizzerà
interessata del mare e di oceanografia e
poi aveva studiato la glaciologia che è
quindi come dire il precursore delle
scienze polari di oggi sapete che oggi
noi abbiamo dei ricercatori in antartide
anche all'artico con delle basi qui
vedete quante basi si sono a livello
internazionale in antartide ora ci sono
dei ricercatori anche il direttore
dell'istituto di scienze polari carlo
barbante in questo momento è in
antartide nelle campagne che servono
proprio come rivelatori dello stato del
pianeta è una tradizione del cnr che
proprio giuseppina aliverti nel
1961 aveva seguito questa è una nave
bannock donata dagli stati uniti al cnr
che fece 15 campagne di registrazione
nel mar tirreno per fondare quelli
trattati che anche lei aveva studiato e
vedete che oggi noi siamo in trattativa
speriamo di riuscirci perché non è
un'impresa semplice perché
dall'australia ci vogliono donare la
nave falcor che una nave oceanografica
ma come vedete le tradizioni lo sapete
bene
non si inventano c'è la storia di oggi e
quindi la delle campagne oceanografiche
noi oggi progettiamo vengono dalle
campagne e scenografiche del passato e
quello di cui oggi ci interessiamo è la
biodiversità il mare quindi le campagne
che noi progettiamo di fare se
riusciremo avere la nostra nuova nave
falcor sarà a studiare e monitorare la
ricchezza della materia vivente nel mare
e in tutto l'universo e nelle nostre
città nelle nostri boschi nelle nostre
foreste sulle montagne perché è il
termometro è la misura dello stato di
salute del pianeta se la biodiversità
diminuisce vuol dire che abbiamo
come dire combinato qualcosa di
sbagliato e per farlo che cosa serve
perché servono tanti soldi per la
ricerca e apparentemente la ricerca
consuma e investimenti perché servono le
infrastrutture di ricerca come aveva
pensato giuseppina aliverti nel 1970 noi
abbiamo bisogno di misuratori rivelatori
che misurino le emissioni di co2
nell'atmosfera
un esempio è l'antenna che noi abbiamo a
capodimonte nel giardino della reggia di
capodimonte noi abbiamo posizionato un
sistema che è un rivelatore della co2
nell'atmosfera per capire la
concentrazione di co2 o abbiamo come
vedete tante infrastrutture
internazionale a che cosa servono il
sogno dei ricercatori di oggi è quello
di costruire queste infrastrutture
misurare tante le aree son nell'area
misurare il mare la biodiversità
misurare e monitorare i parametri fisici
chimici bio chimici biologici rilevanti
mettere in rete i dati di queste misure
e renderle accessibili a tutta la
comunità scientifica ma anche ai
cittadini la novità di oggi e
dell'evoluzione scientifica comporta
quello che noi chiamiamo open science
che significa accesso alla scienza e se
thyssen senza cioè gli scienziati i
cittadini e comunque chiunque deve poter
accedere alle informazioni e ai
parametri che misurano per esempio lo
stato del pianeta ai modelli che i
ricercatori applicano ed essere come
convinti e coinvolti perché se non
cambiamo il comportamento di tutti non
riusciremo mai a mitigare l'impatto del
cambiamento climatico a tornare indietro
ea vivere la nostra transizione perché
noi oggi abbiamo un grande obiettivo un
grande sogno quello della transizione
ecologica la transizione ecologica
dipende da una parte dalla nostra
capacità di trasformare la chimica
dall'ideale in circolare cioè
riutilizzare i materiali
riutilizzare i processi cambiare il
verso del consumo e indefinito di
risorse e cambiarlo in modo sostanziale
quindi cambiare il nostro approccio
inserire nelle equazioni che descrivono
la realtà anche i parametri che
riguardano il consumo di energia
riguardano quanto noi sprechiamo quanto
noi immettiamo inquinanti nel mondo e
quindi ha un modo diverso di descrivere
la realtà che i nostri figli i nostri
nipoti comunque dovranno cominciare a
cambiare quindi il comportamento nostro
di tutti noi deve cambiare per vivere
questa transizione e dobbiamo anche noi
ricercatori imparare a comunicare a
mettere in rete i dati che noi otteniamo
che è che noi riveliamo perché sono un
patrimonio di tutti noi viviamo con le
tasse che voi pagate con le tasse dei
cittadini ed è giusto che noi
rendicontiamo e raccontiamo e spieghiamo
al mondo quello che noi facciamo
quindi infine per tornare alla mia amata
da giuseppina diverti che per me è un
grande modello
cosa abbiamo imparato da lei prima di
tutto abbiamo imparato che si può
studiare una materia e poi sviluppare un
settore scientifico un'attività un un
progetto che attraverso i settori della
scienza ed entri in in altri ambiti la è
partita dalla fisica ha fatto la
geofisica ha fatto la glaciologia
all'oceanografia ha diretto istituti ha
lavorato per il bene del suo paese
pensava di essere al servizio del suo
paese ha organizzato campagne nei mari
ma abbiamo anche imparato un altro
aspetto che è molto importante nella
scienza di oggi con cui voglio
concludere questo mio breve intervento
che oggi
esiste una consapevolezza fondamentale
in ricercatori che ne ricercatori prima
di tutto che il nostro compito è aiutare
e lavorare fra discipline differenti da
quelle più delle scienze dure fino a
quelle umanistiche per trasformare la
ricerca in cultura perché soltanto
quando diventa cultura può cambiare i
comportamenti e far partecipare i
cittadini a questa grande rivoluzione
scientifica che noi dobbiamo vivere
questa grande rivoluzione industriale
che per la prima volta nella storia
dell'uomo è una rivoluzione industriale
che vuole essere
sostenibile e quindi non devastare
l'ambiente ma essere compatibile con
l'ambiente penso che sia il grande sogno
di oggi che è talmente condiviso da
essere così dire sembrare quasi ovvio ma
invece comporta davvero un cambio
culturale profondo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]